[Music]
since the day she opened her eyes she
knew she was born to fly to live a life
of adventure to explore to adsorb to
find something more with no restrictions
she chose discrete to stay comfortably
on her feet because she was more than
just a woman she'll take her shot she'll
remain strong because she remembered to
buy yeah you betcha no time of the month
she'd spoil your fun yeah coupons
because girls every day is your day to
show the world who you really are is
life
[Music]
I've just finished my 14-hour journey to
San Francisco but it was kind of like
longer than that because I had to travel
to the airport so you guys don't care
about that I am here to do some
videography work with my old work qsr
which I'm super excited about some
Encinos them as the longest is like it's
exciting and then I am going to be
exploring San Francisco a little bit so
I've got this grand hotel room while I'm
working and then I'm paying for my own
hostel afterwards because let me show
you around
bathroom Oh lights camera action there's
actually they give you some really cool
toiletries
I freaking I freaking love her toe
because I don't know why they just like
excite me like so much I love that
they've thought of this just in case you
have any noisy neighbors but obviously I
am the noisy neighbor online yep that'd
be me follow me in the bedroom watch
this
fancy smancy yeah what will get me going
through the next three or four days of
work wait what I'm here for like a
second and I'm already like making a
mess with the coffee
why's wrong with me I just didn't like
it just it just overflowed like I don't
know I don't I don't
[Music]
[Music]
I have been blessed today with a bit of
a lion and yeah I've got some emails to
write back to you hook for F and D up my
phone because I didn't bring my laptop
cuz that would have been one too many
electrical equipments to take with me
I've got the program for the events that
I'm helping down which is called
reimagine education and it's pretty cool
it's about like using technology and
stuff to like reimagine education it all
makes sense
um yeah and I'll probably take some
shots of San Francisco maybe but it's
like very rainy today so I don't want to
get my camera wet wet but we shall we
shall see voila transformation complete
this is what happens when young man X
gets given too much free time I actually
wear makeup but it's probably about time
then I read the hotel room and go and
find myself some breakfast because
apparently there the pancake house
around the corner who knew this but
actually gonna go but um I need to go
and then carry on with my day of work
but I feel like I'll be just I don't
know come here and okay yeah finally in
vain whatever baby alone
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's currently day 2 of filming and this
is our interview room we have a backdrop
we've been interviewing a lot of
interesting educators from startup
companies to even Google so it's been
very interesting I got a bunch of fruit
and things so that we don't go hungry
today so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know if I'll keep this in but
it's been playing on my mind I just want
to apologize for not not making enough
videos cuz I don't know it's just really
annoying as I'm constantly battling
between wanting to make more consistent
content but also making better better
content and oh cuz I do you things like
this like this vlog and everything and
hopefully this is gonna go up but this
is easier to edit them and say some of
my ideas that I know are probably gonna
take weeks and weeks and through those
weeks I will feel guilty about not
uploading more regularly what's your
name
I'm sure I get a lot of you know
comments and people just say I love you
really user bah blah and then unless you
feel like guilty because I don't do
enough them and I know a lot of you guys
don't even ask
for like massively amazingly produce
content you just want to see me like do
whatever whether it's me Sal toilette
talking to you which is what I'm doing
right now or if it's you know one of my
well planned out ideas or new music
video or something it doesn't really
matter but in my head it it really does
and then can't see like overthinking
everything like everyone's telling me I
need to click meat and things like that
to get more more views than all things
but I just feel like constantly bad
some types of things like I don't know
I'm just so terrible at coming up with
clickbait titles because I don't want I
don't they I guess like whenever I make
a video I only really make it because
it's something that I'm really
interested in or like it excites me
which isn't really a business minded way
of doing anything but oh wow this is my
home my mobile struggles with YouTube on
and off all the time
and I've explained this in multiple
videos it's me trying to remind myself
why I do YouTube but at the same time I
am I do apologize I wish I could make
more videos and have more time but
unfortunately I have to do one thing at
a time because I'm human and right now I
really really really need to prioritize
this album so I'm just trying to this is
kind of therapy for me
oh yeah I'm annex therapy insert into
the vlog prioritize do the EP I need to
get the door returned the songs are down
there
the songs are done and I just need to
amuse it therefore see ya one thing I
find one thing at a time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
last night in a hostel hello from the
big fancy smancy hotel room I've been
saying yeah but it's always quite nice
to stay somewhere different especially a
hostel because you always meet different
people I like to come in here and just
chat to whoever's in the room it's a
nice different scene but I can tell you
now I said to fall pretty much 14-hour
days and last night going to eat some
really tasty sushi actually no it was
ramen with them the people in the hostel
I am freaking tired and I'm dreading
this 14-hour journey back home please
let there be
I do have snacks though I've brought
some like flamin hot cheetos and some
other hot crisps and some sriracha nuts
so I'm prepared I am prepared let's go
get this bar like a train one thing that
like I I guess I didn't like learn on
this journey but I've just realized it's
the truth is honestly be nice to
everybody when I was working as a
videographer I was nice too I was sooo
nice nice it'd be nice gets you so sort
of just treat everyone the same sense of
decency no matter what like job well
they are or like whether they're like
above or below you in hierarchy just be
nice to everyone and good things come
back to you because these past few days
have been very hard work but because I
was always doing my best slightly smiley
be happy and be nice to everyone they
were like the same back to me and people
noticed that if you're happy towards
them they'll be happy towards you and it
in turn makes your day easier my little
nugget of wisdom for the vlog and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]